(upbeat music)
- [Kelly] Hello, and scene.
- [Zachary] Hi
- Um... I'm...
- You look fabulous
- Thank you. It's Christmas.
- It is
- [Kelly] I don't usually dress
like a person from the forties,
Um, but
(kelly laughs)
but it went with the vibe.
Uhm, no, but I know you know Jessie,
but how'd y'all meet again?
- [Zachary] Well, we me
through mutual friends
years and years ago.
And then actually,
so, I did this movie called
"Tangled" for Disney
and when I was auditioning. Yeah...-
(audience cheering)
- We love "Tangled."
- You're welcome.
You're welcome. So, but Jess..
- Are you talking about Flynn Rider? What?
- Flynn Rider
- What? I'm sorry.
- You, yeah, yeah.
You know, you know
- I know the whole thing [Kelly Giggles].
- Yeah, but so she was
also auditioning for it,
and we bumped back into each other and...
- Yeah.
- She's my nugget, she's
my muse. I love her.
She's like, she's deeper than family.
I love that girl so much.
- [Jessie] I love you baby
- Oh that's right, you did do,
you recorded some of the songs.
- I did all the original demos.
- I remember you to me about that
Yeah, I did all the original demos.
And when I met you,
it was in Toronto at your show
- It was
and I sat on a ping pong
table and destroyed it.
(kelly laughs)
- [Jessie] Yes, you did.
- So she had to pay for it, probably.
- [Jessie] But you held on your drink!
- You held... That was the best part.
but you held on your drink and
- Yeah
- And I was like, he can stay.
- [Zachary] Oh yeah.
(Kelly Laughing)
(audience laughs)
- I'm sorry.
That's awesome.
- Yeah!
- [Kelly] Anyway, congrats
on American underdog.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] This is, this is an
amazing thing
(audience cheering)
its based on a true story,
which is the coolest part
- Yip. Yeah, I mean, it's,
it's a really incredible, I mean,
Cinderella story that,
you know, a lot of us,
we watched in real time,
it happened not too long ago and it's,
that part is incredible.
The football part of it.
But the movie is really like
twenty-five percent football,
75% family and faith and life and,
the struggle through life, and you know,
all that it takes, and to get to those
dreams that you felt like
God gave you when you were a kid,
like that kind of stuff.
Even to the point where... -
[Kelly] That's what I love.
The back story.
- Yeah, yeah
- And Brenda, and she's an underdog
and her son, Zach,
and how he's an underdog and
scrape and change out of your
car doors to put gas in
the tank, like you know
that kind of stuff
- [Kelly] Yeah!
and all the way to this, you know,
the scene that you saw. You know uh that,
that moment, it,
it took the whole family
unit for Kurt, I think,
to ultimately get to that dream.
And it's just beautiful.
- [Kelly] I love that because people
(crowd cheering)
don't generally see that.
They don't generally see anything,
but, them being like, you know,
some rich and famous sports star
- Yeah, exactly!
- [Kelly] and it's like, well,
we all came from somewhere.
You like people in
the limelight, we all came from somewhere.
- [Zachary] 100%
- and one of our beginnings
were, so,
- Yeah
I think that's the coolest part
about it is that you get
to really like dive in and it's
awesome that they let you
into their family.
Did you actually like talk to
the family and get to like hang out?
- [Zachary] Oh, yeah, yeah.
I mean, for a couple days,
I got to hang out with Kurt and Brenda
and meet their kids.
And that was amazing.
And then Kurt and Brenda were
with us maybe probably more
than 50% of the time...
- [Kelly] Oh that's cool.
- While we were shooting it,
which was amazing because you know,
you have this resource to instantly
go to and say like, "Hey,
what would happened right here?
Like, what did you do?
What were your mannerisms,
how were you feeling in this moment?"
And Anna and I had these
incredible people to just,
you know, guide us through that. So...
- [Kelly] Yeah, great cast.
- Yeah!
(audience clapping)
Oh Anna's fantastic!
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- no, it's great.
- Well, I love this about you though.
You love music. Actually,
I remember Jessie telling me that
you love music so much
- I do.
- And you did so
great with tangled,
but I hear you actually,
DJ on set. Is this?
- Well, I mean,
- are you like a wiki, wiki?
- [ Zachary] I mean no,
see, that's the thing.
I wish I could Wiki Wiki,
but I don't wiki, wiki.
(audience laughs)
- Uh I have...
- Are you like I pull up my playlist?
- Exactly.
- [Kelly] Yeah okay.
- And I bring these really fun,
big Bluetooth speakers,
and I just play tunes for
the cast and the crew.
And I just love like
anything with the boogie
anything with the boogie baby, you know!
(kelly laughs, claps)
- Anything with the boogie
- [Kelly] Alright, alright
Um, do you ever get Kurt to sing along,
cause he was there 50% of the time.
- [Zachary] No, no, no, yes!
So, so, he was, he is
a very chill laid back
cool customer.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But, uh, there is certain music that
I could get him really
into, and ironically
you know I've done
Broadway a couple of times,
and I'm very, very proud of the Broadway,
that I've done.
I had no idea that Kurt
was a huge Broadway fan.
- [Kelly] Wait what?
(boom sound) It blew my mind.
His favorite show is Aida
and he's seen it...
- [Kelly] What?
- like a dozen times.
He's seen it like a dozen times!
And so, and so, very surrep..
Surreptitiously
that's the word
- [Kelly] Surreptitiously
- I started playing Aida,
and I put it next to his chair
and then I could see,
I'm kinda watching him
and he starts to sing into it a little bit
I was like ah ha!
- [Kelly] (laughs)
- I got you!
- [Kelly] I got you! That's awesome
I would have never guessed
that, that's awesome
- Yeah, never in a million years.
- [Kelly] That's very well rounded.
- Yeah, I think so.
He is a 360 human being.
- [Kelly] Yes, yes.